the philosopher Plato once said music
gives a soul to the universe wings the
mind flight to the imagination and life
to everything music has always been a
big part of my life to create the
perform music connects you to people
countries and lifetimes away it connects
you to the people you're playing with
your audience and to yourself when I'm
happy when I'm sad when I'm bored when
I'm stressed I listen to and I create
music when I was younger I played piano
later I took up guitar and as I started
high school music became a part of my
identity I was in every band I was
involved with every musical Fine Arts
event
music surrounded me it made me who I was
and it gave me a place to belong now
I've always had this thing with rhythms
I remember being young I would walk down
the hallways of my school and I would
tap rhythms to myself on their leg with
my hands or tapping my teeth it was a
nervous habit and I was always nervous I
think I like the repetition of the
rhythm
it was calming then in high school I
started music theory and as the best
class I've ever taken we were learning
about music things I didn't know like
theory and history it was a class where
we basically just listened to a song
talked about what it meant to us and
analyzed it and figured out what needed
take and every Wednesday we did
something called rhythmic dictation and
I was pretty good at it our teacher
would give us an amount of measures and
then time signature and then she would
speak a rhythm to us and we would have
to write it down with the proper rest
and notes like this tah-tah-tah-tah
tah-tah ticka ticka ticka ticka and i
loved it the simplicity of the rhythm of
basic two to four measure line and
each of them almost told a story like
they had so much potential and all you
had to do was add a melody rhythm set a
foundation for melodies and harmonies
the plan top of it gives structure and
stability the music has these parts
rhythm melody and harmony just like our
lives where music has rhythm we have
routines and habits things that help us
to remember what to do and to stay on
track and to just keep going and you may
not notice it but it's always there
it may seem simple it may seem dull by
itself but it gives tempo and heartbeat
and then sings in your life let on to it
giving textures as your friends and your
family and anything that creates a
harmonic structure in your life and in
your song like harmonies Cadence's and
anything that makes it polyphonic and
they create beautiful chords and pattern
and then the view you play on top of
everything else on top of the rhythm and
the beat you're the melody and things
may change and develop but no matter
what we do we're still different people
throw the song melody develops but it's
still the same song no matter what you
do while rhythms are still there the
temple and the heartbeat until I left
and I went to college and everything
disappeared when I first arrived at
University I felt lost don't get me
wrong
sometimes I loved it and it was great
but other times I felt like I had been
left alone to fend for myself like I'd
been taken out of my natural environment
and put somewhere new where the rhythms
and the harmonies and the form had gone
away and it was just me silence and my
melody
and even that began the Weaver doesn't
know what I was doing I didn't have any
cords destruction myself or a rhythm or
beat to know the temple I'm going to be
in zero these other sounds and they were
off time and off key the more I was
around them more my melody spread this
sound like theirs and slowly I began to
lose myself
it goes being washed away
within the next moment
I could hear it
and I could feel it and it was me and I
was here and it was different the MAL
worse off just change the little music
is my way of coping with the changes in
my life there's a beautiful connection
between music and life can bind us to
reality at the same time it allows us to
escape it music is something that lives
inside of you you create it and you're
created by it now our lives are not only
conducted by music they're also composed
of it so this may seem like a bit of a
stretch but hear me out music is a
fundamental part of what we are and if
everything around us now music is my
passion but physics also used to be an
interest of mine and the more I learned
the more I saw connections between the
two especially regarding string theory
now I know this is only one of many
theories but it spoke to me so one
aspect of string theory at its simplest
form is this matter is made of atoms
which I made up those protons and
neutrons and electrons which I made up
of cork and here the string part comes
in this Court is supposedly made up of
little coiled strings and it's the
vibrations in these strings that make
everything what what it is
Michio Kaku once explained this an
electric called the universe in a
nutshell where he says string theory is
a simple idea that the four forces of
the universe gravity the electromagnetic
force and the two strong forces can be
viewed as music the music of tiny little
rubber bands in this lecture he goes on
to explain physics of the laws of
harmony between these strings chemistry
as the melodies you can play on these
strings and he states that the universe
is a symphony of strings these two
dictate the universe they make up
everything we see and everything we know
the musical notes but they make us what
we are and they hold us together so you
see everything is music when I look at
the world I see music all around us
[Music]
when I look at myself I see music my
life has been defined by music I found
myself through music music is everywhere
and it is in everything and it changes
the bill and it diminishes
there's always there supporting us
connecting this to each other and
showing us the beauty of the universe so
if the other few lost stop and listen
for your song thank you
[Applause]